FIRST, THE ANATOMY OF A SMEAR.
THAT'S THE SUBJECT OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
TODAY'S LEFT LEANING MEDIA
COMPLEX FANCY THEMSELVES AS THE
ONLY RELIABLE CHECK ON THE
PRESIDENT.
SURE, CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS
CAN GIVE SPEECHES AND FILE
MINORITY REPORTS ON CAPITOL HILL
AND BOB MUELLER MAY BE GETTING
WARMER.
BUT THE PRESS BELIEVES IT HAS A
SUPERIOR MORAL RESPONSIBILITY
NOT NECESSARILY TO RESPECT THE
TRUTH BUT TO REPORT A VERSION OF
THE TRUTH IN A WAY THAT IS
SKEWED AGAINST TRUMP AND HIS
ALLIES.
HENCE, THEY TAKE A COMMENT ABOUT
HIM ABOUT MS-13 MEMBERS.
>> MS-13 GANG MEMBERS.
>> WE HAVE PEOPLE COMING INTO
THE COUNTRY OR TRYING TO COME
IN, WE ARE STOPPING A LOT OF
THEM.
WE ARE TAKING PEOPLE OUT OF THE
COUNTRY.
YOU WOULD NOT BELIEVE HOW BAD
THESE PEOPLE ARE.
THESE ARE NOT PEOPLE.
THESE ARE ANIMALS.
>> Laura: AND THEY TURN THAT
COMMENT INTO THIS:
TRUMP RANT ON UNAUTHORIZED
MIGRANTS.
THESE ARE ANIMALS SAID THE "NEW
YORK TIMES."
AND THE NEW YORK DAILY NEWS.
AND THE HUFFINGTON POST
SQUAWKED:
NOW THIS IS AN OBSCENE AND
RIDICULOUS AND FRANKLY NEFARIOUS
PLAN THAT GETS PICKED UP BY
LIBERAL POLITICIANS LIKE CHUCK
SCHUMER WHO WROTE THE FOLLOWING:
WHEN ALL OF OUR GREAT, GREAT
GRANDPARENTS CAME TO AMERICA,
THEY WERE NOT ANIMALS AND THESE
PEOPLE WERE NOT EITHER.
ON TV THEY BOUNCE CONDEMNATIONS
AROUND THE ECHO CHAMBER.
>> WHAT DID THE PRESIDENT MEAN
WHEN HE SAID IMMIGRANTS ARE
ANIMALS?
>> IT'S A DISGUSTING WAY TO TALK
ABOUT HUMAN BEINGS.
>> IT'S A SLIPPERY SLOPE WHEN
YOU DEHUMANIZE PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHAT THE NAZIS AND SLAVE
OWNERS DID.
IT'S NOT WHAT AMERICANS DID.
>> THE TONE SHIFTED ABOUT WHAT
IT MEANS IF YOU ARE AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT.
>> Laura: YES, SHE WENT TO
NAZIS.
OH MY GOD, DO ANY OF THESE
PEOPLE BOTHER TO TRY TO LOOK
LIKE THEY ARE IN ANY WAY
IMPARTIAL, CALLING BALLS AND
STRIKES?
YOU KNOW, LEARN THE FACTS OR
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE CONTEXT OF
THE PRESIDENT SAID OR GET OUT OF
THE BUSINESS!
TO READ BEYOND THE HEADLINES AND
REPORT THE TRUTH.
EVEN ANALYSTS, BOTHER TO READ
THE FULL COMMENTS AND BE FAIR!
SPEAKING OF BEING FAIR, JAKE
TAPPER AND CNN THEY DID NOTE
THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS TAKEN OUT
OF CONTEXT EARLIER TODAY AND THE
AP AKNOWLEDGED IT MADE AN HONOR
MISTAKE.
THEY DELETED A TWEET ABOUT
TRUMP'S COMMENTS ABOUT
IMMIGRANTS BECAUSE IT WAS NOT
MADE CLEAR IT WAS A COMMENT
ABOUT GANG MEMBERS.
EVEN AFTER THOSE CLARIFICATIONS
MSNBC COULD NOT HELP ITSELF.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP LASHING OUT
AND STIRRING CONTROVERSY OVER
HIS HARSH RECORD TOWARDS
IMMIGRANTS BRANDING THEM
ANIMALS.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAID HE WAS
REFERRING TO THE CRIMINAL
IMMIGRANT GANG MS-13 AND NOT TO
ALL IMMIGRANTS.
HE DIDN'T MAKE THAT CLEAR.
>> Laura: HE WAS RESPONDING TO A
POINT ABOUT MS-13, ANDREA.
SHE KNOWS BETTER!
THIS, MY FRIEND, IS THE ANATOMY
OF A SMEAR.
TAKE A COMMENT OUT OF CONTEXT.
ISOLATE IT.
BLAST OUT THE WORST POSSIBLE
CHARACTERIZATION OF ITS PURPOSE
AND MEANING AND WRITERS AND
REPORTERS AND POLITICIANS SPIT
IT BACK ON PANELS WHERE THE
NUMBERS THE NUMBER OF BRAIN
CELLS.
AS FOR MS-13, ABOUT WHOM TRUMP
WAS SPEAKING, THIS IS SOME OF
WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN UP TO
LATELY.
IN A HORR IF
IN A HORR I
IN A HORRIF
IN A HORRIFIC
IN A HORRIFIC C
IN A HORRIFIC CRI
IN A HORRIFIC CRIME
IN A HORRIFIC CRIME I
IN A HORRIFIC CRIME IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. MS-13 MEMBERS
STABBED A MAN AND DECAPITATED
HIM AND TORE THE HEART RIGHT OUT
OF HIS CHEST.
OR IN VIRGINIA, WHERE AN MS-13
GANG MEMBER BEAT A MUSLIM GIRL
TO DEATH WITH A BASEBALL BAT.
AND MURDERING A 17-YEAR-OLD
MUSLIM GIRL WAS ACCUSED OF
SEXUALLY ASSAULTING ANOTHER
WOMAN A WEEK BEFORE THE TEEN
SLAYING IN VIRGINIA AND AN MS-13
GANG MEMBER.
THEN THERE IS THIS HEART
BREAKING ACCOUNT FROM THE
PARENTS OF TEENAGE GIRLS KILLED
BY MS-13 IN NEW YORK.
>> THERE IS NOT A DAY, A SECOND,
THAT I DON'T THINK ABOUT MY
AND, HMMM, THEY JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE PAIN OF A PARENT
LOSING A CHILD TO THIS GANG
VIOLENCE.
I HOPE THEY NEVER WILL.
OUR KIDS SHOULD BE BURYING US,
NOT THE PARENTS BURYING THEIR
KIDS.
THEIR LIVES ARE AHEAD OF THEM.
>> Laura: THAT WAS ONE OF THE
TOUGHEST INTERVIEWS I HAVE DONE
IN THE HISTORY OF THIS SHOW.
THE PAIN ON A MOTHER'S FACE.
AS IF THINGS COULD NOT GET
WORSE, THE SUSPECTS IN THAT CASE
WERE SEEN LAUGHING IN COURT
DURING A PRE-TRIAL HEARING.
UNBELIEVABLE.
NO WONDER SARAH SANDERS
RESPONDED THIS WAY TO THE ANIMAL
FRACUS AT TODAY'S BRIEFING.
>> THE TERM ANIMAL DOESN'T GO
FAR ENOUGH.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
CONTINUE TO USE HIS PLATFORM AND
EVERYTHING HE CAN DO UNDER THE
LAW TO STOP THESE TIMES OF
HORRIBLE, HORRIBLE, DISGUSTING
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: GOOD FOR HER.
I WOULD SAY WE ARE INSULTING
ANIMALS.
THEY DON'T BEHAVE THIS WAY OR
KILL FOR FUN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE LAST WORD ON THIS GOES TO
THE PRESIDENT.
WHO CLEARED UP ANY CONFUSION FOR
ALL OF THOSE COMMENTATORS ON
MSNBC WITH HIS COMMENTS TODAY.
>> I AM REFERRING AND YOU KNOW I
AM REFERRING TO THE MS-13 GANGS
THAT ARE COMING IN.
WHEN THE MS-13 COMES IN, THE
OTHER GANG MEMBERS COME INTO OUR
COUNTRY, I REFER TO THEM AS
ANIMALS, AND I ALWAYS WILL.
>> Laura: THIS IS WHY TRUMP GOT
ELECTED BY SPEAKING BLUNTY AND
HONESTLY.
NOT A LOT OF CONCERN FOR
POLITICAL CORRECT INNS.
-- CORRECTNESS.
PEOPLE ARE DONE WITH THAT
ANYWAY.
HE IS TALKING IT LAW AND ORDER.
HE CHANGED THE POLITICAL
LANDSCAPE AND FRUSTRATED LIBERAL
NARRATIVES BY SPEAKING TO THE
PEOPLE AS THEY SPEAK AMONG
THEMSELVES.
IF HE KEEPS UP THAT FOCUS, HE
WILL GET ELECTED AGAIN.
PERHAPS, THAT'S WHY THE LEFT IS
ACTING LIKE A PACK OF WILD